[Music]
pick and roll takes off by the
touchscreen to get them selves over
going to the basket yes punch
right-handed hair he came in believing
the NBA with 50 shades dr. 28 at this
point he's got the count ability when he
struggles like that from one area in the
slam zone great games off the bench
against Detroit Cleveland the last road
trip is gold medalist in the triple jump
when you watch to see what he could do
at the bat I want to set the screen down
to three look how far they push to Barry
down the lane for the
they got a mismatch
if you stick a jumper with seven seconds
left or something the Clippers will have
an opportunity step let the clock point
five he knew what he was doing curry
fakes all rifles a pass to take it
toppled with a point nine remaining
plays on the offensive end Steph Curry
taken the double-team finding a wide
open target Iguodala for your defense
their 16th in the league and efficient
defensive efficiency Kareem I expect
curry
sweetly there from Steph pellet shots he
works on because not by accident he
works on these shots
[Applause]
[Music]
deep Chris Harbor guard that finding
should know that he's going to take this
as the clock winds down to the halftime
break that is what he does Butler nice
hustle McConnell think King three sixes
two over fresh fourteen and be spotty
but this time it's the diminutive
Burke's
on him with the reverse dribble making
it look there's looking to go in front
of they do so it'll be the 13th lead
change of this game and beat again that
tiny night through the doubles a people
attempt by Galan right to stop that man
two defenders and see active no chance
who comes right a little bit too late
by the Rockets on us here comes Harden
with her
[Applause]
that's here
[Music]
and that's it has been a haunting rocks
by envy look at the block here by envy
which is beautiful you guys you want
your big there's Looney with the board
now in B which like Chandler got a piece
of that second try by Looney good pass
and
Maxon bull so l impede a bang going
windmills put him in a slam dunk contest
here in this quarter little Paul George
to make a beautiful pass and George with
the slam q ssin OnPoint delivery little
back there's George puts it on the floor
gets passed to
[Applause]
[Music]
Westbrook did that dunk over Yanis with
ssweet in the truck and they make the
call
George oh my goodness
Paul George bouncing off of Isaac the
time to drop the mic I don't have a mic
in my hand but this is amazing folks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
talk about access denied at the rim ball
George just perfect timing
him but doing his thing he's got Lions
on skates that's it
[Applause]
man my skates I would just go for the
first bake and leave alone really
unfortunate
that would be a foul and the basket what
a shot
let's step in a good ball fake and it's
a three oh absolutely
into the corners college time through it
where he was
[Applause]
the words my man just time and score and
nobody does the best then the point
guards in this league renovate this
arena have it all start game here they
throw it into the back court
Kemba Walker avoiding Josh Jackson and
down though this through it from
midcourt pretty sure that did not count
but it was a fabulous finish who scored
the last 11 Charlotte big discount it
did did he get it off I think it did
count and Milton wanted this shot
shattered with confidence shot clock at
three
bill drives baseline knocked away put up
oh that is a killer with the shot clock
winding down Middleton you saw that he
gathered straight that elbow out yo
kitch comes to set the screen with five
seconds left
here's your pitch over Pam Oh get that
shot the art did high over to out
stretch arms from Anna bio but the
go-ahead score with just over two
seconds watch jamal berry with the
delivery on the bounce pass and Yogesh
just gets it up there with that soft
touch
Marketing the only player in double
figures well did the message happen it
what's this there's a screen right there
by Murray and then that's it that is
just a nice plate
foul on Levine that looked like it was
going to be one-on-one for Chris Paul
all the way up until the book
like a jet and through it
to tie the score at 103 bass rock to
dribble 51 two nights ago Blake Griffin
against the night show and go home man
knocks it down it gets to ran out of
position allowing Blake to attack that
from ramen and dumpling was already on
his mood and Billy had time to pull back
[Applause]
rustle scratches the back of the day
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that's nasty gross
that's especially their clothes of time
[Applause]
versus need feed for Russell likes the
matchup fakes
[Applause]
rustle some trickery and he got the two
shots blocked because he went up right
there with it and it was blocked Russell
that hesitate a lot of time left eight
and 38 to play in the third Russell
trying to turn the corner
nasty move by DeAngelo Russell and
Denver does not know what hit them
Russell looking from the back door
initially on this ready nobody home
little flip shot the finished Jonathan
Simmons
[Applause]
Nicola who slobo Booch
[Applause]
three-point Nets lead matches their
biggest boots events with the powerhouse
Dan Kneen plays David watch Nikola boots
a [ __ ] on the roll with a finish over
the job by a brooder denying siak of
Kyle
bucket and pumpkin hitting his hands in
a ball like this at a bio is no time on
the clock you got to get up and take
this shot away
Kyle able to knock it down which is
basically played zone that play trying
to keep antics truthful from penetrating
Maori but then I strive inside all-star
for a fifth time in his career
fortunately issue around Hill Lucas
swings it to Dirk
[Applause]
there's a swing over the dirt number ten
second career triple-double for Dennis
Smith jr. the next key
[Applause]
well points for Dirk Nowitzki yeah
painting the Knicks sweet string music